Yeah, this is Jad, Radiolab. So what you're about to hear, uh,
is a show we originally released about six, seven years ago.
We decided to revisit it recently cause it's been on our minds a lot. Um,
let's just, I'll start it off and then I'll say more about it in a second.
Oh wait, you're listening.
You are listening to radio lab radio from W N y.
S. T. E. Yep.
Okay. You Ready? Yup. All right. Let's open the show today.
Test, test, test on a sunny street corner. Okay. In New Jersey.
So where are we now? We are on Washington Street,
which is the main thoroughfare in Hoboken. It's a nice day in Hoboken.
People are out and about after work cause that Sangria.
What do you guys and we're here with the guy, his name's John Horgan.
I'm a science journalist. He's also a teacher. Oh it is hot. Yeah.
John is out today with our producer Lulu Miller doing what he often does,
which is to go up to someone who doesn't know research. We're doing a survey,
only take a minute at most minute I can give you that.
He asked them this one question as the question,
will humans ever stop fighting wars once and for all?
[inaudible]
no, because of greed
and one upsmanship to explain. John has been asking this question,
will humans ever stop fighting wars for years? Because for him, this question,
it's not just about war, it gets it something really basic.
Do we feel we can change who we are?
[inaudible]
in any case, the first time it popped out of his mouth,
it was 2003 and a friend had asked him to give a talk at a church just a few
days after the first invasion of Iraq,
and so here I was in this church and I can remember that blued was very somber.
I was determined to try to make people feel that, okay,
this is a setback, but still you've got to believe that peace is possible.
And I tried to list all the reasons
[inaudible]
and as he was making his case and getting worked up,
you looked at the 60 or so people who were there in the audience. He said,
all right, how many of you here believe that war will end some day?
[inaudible]
and I think one or two people raised their hands out of 68
and John Thought, wait,
is this really who you are?
And so that's actually when I started reading as much as I can about all these
things and dug up some surveys from the 1980s what he found was that about 20
years ago, 80 people were asking this question,
do you think war will ever end taking surveys?
Now granted they were not the most scientific of surveys,
but what the results seem to indicate is that we used to be optimistic back in
the 80s only one and three thought that war is inevitable, huh?
As a minority. Yeah. Whereas today, well,
humans ever stop fighting wars once and for all.
If you take that question to the streets of Hoboken as we did, you'll find
no, no, no, no, no, no.
About nine out of 10 people say, no,
no, no, never. No, never. No.
By the way,
we call up John again recently to ask them have the results changed cause he has
kept on doing this survey and he said, no. Uh, six years later,
it's still roughly eight or nine out of 10. People say, no,
we'll never stop fighting wars. Same results right now, depressingly.
The worst part is that when he asked him the next question,
why do you think this? Invariably he gets something like,
I think there's a human nature's too for greed and to always want more.
It's just human nature.
A lot of people are big dumb animals and they're just going to keep fighting
over useless things in their genes. It's just the way people,
and I don't think we're ever going to learn. Why do you say that?
I just think that it's too ingrained in our human nature, so,
so, so, so, so we want to challenge that last statement
too ingrained in our human nature.
Okay.
We know some things have been handed down to us from our primate ancestors.
Violence. Maybe who knows. Question is, how ingrained is that stuff? Well, yeah,
I mean, if you think that we have inherited something yet,
where can we do about it?
Or are we stuck or can we change if we make the right choices? Yeah.
So what we've got for you this hour are three stories. We're choice,
individual choice challenges, destiny, right? Maybe we hope. Yeah,
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab stick around.
[inaudible]
alright, so here's the thing. This is now me and the present. Um,
this show was initially inspired by, uh,
an anecdote that I'd read about in the New York Times. This Guy Martin Bunzl,
uh, was telling a story of when he was 18. It was in 1966, I believe.
He was sitting on a plane and a guy next to him said it looks at the stewardess
and then says, oh, not another negro stewardess or something like that.
And, um, this guy, Martin Bunzl, who by the way, it's a philosophy professor,
he says, thinking back on it, Huh?
That was an interesting thing because how'd that guy on the plane said that a
few years earlier it would have been like commonplace.
Had he said it a few years later it would have been intolerable,
but right then it was neither.
It was things were shifting and he said, you know,
it was like this guy was shouting through an open window between worlds.
That was his phrase.
He was shouting through an open window between worlds and that phrase totally
lodged in my head and I've been thinking about that a lot these days,
this feeling that maybe the ground is shifting beneath our feet, not quite sure.
And that's actually what brought us back to this show, that feeling,
because each of the stories in this show kind of suggest that window between
worlds. So what we're going to do is as we redo the show after a couple of these
stories,
we're going to check in real quick and see whether we feel like we've passed
through this window into a new world or whether we're still stuck in the middle.
In speaking of new worlds by you, which we should say you just heard, uh,
Lulu Miller, uh, briefly in that last few minutes.
She at the time was our producer.
Now of course she's become the superstar host of Invisibilia. Anyhow,
so the show began, uh, with
a familiar voice.
Remember this guy I'm Robert Sapolsky on, Oh yeah, that's Robert Sapolsky.
We've had him on the show a couple of times. He's a neuroscientist,
spends most of the year at Stanford being a lab rep,
scientists doing neurobiology in the lab. But in the summers, most summers, um,
I go and spend time in east Africa,
in the Serengeti studying wild baboons there. Why?
What is it, what is he working on?
What's this reason to suppose he is interested in studying stress,
the effect that stress has on the body and turns out baboons are a perfect
source of data because they're always under stress.
No, the one thing we know about baboons and have known forever
is it, they fight baboons constantly, not just metaphorically,
but literally have been the textbook example of a highly aggressive male
dominated hierarchical society.
Because these animals hunt because they live in these aggressive troops on the
Savannah parentheses, just like we humans used to invest.
We evolved very similarly. They have a constant baseline level of aggression,
which inevitably spills over into their social lives,
which is why he studied them. So what's supposed to,
he does basically is he goes into the Bush and he watches,
I mean your field notes though. There's a floor them there and a whole shelter.
His office is covered with these field notebooks.
Each one containing detailed notes of who groomed who and who's not getting
along with who and who's messing around with who in the bushes.
He tells the following story of a particular moment in his baboo watching,
which completely changed his life,
changed how he sees the world. It happened about 30 years ago.
Spolsky was a young guy just out of Grad school studying his first troop, my,
my first baboons troop. He really loved these animals.
I was very connected with numerous ways. It was a pretty average group. Yeah.
Your basic Bab balloon troop.
The females were highly affiliated with each other. Um,
they had a very stable ranking system. The males, meanwhile,
the highly aggressive dumping on each other cause that's just what males do,
right? So we thought,
okay, mid eighties, a big boom and in Kenya,
wonders for the economy, lots of new lodges, lots of large expansions.
And there happened to be the next territory over the tourist lodge.
And this one particular lodge he says, had gotten really big really fast.
And during the time the lodge greatly expanded their garbage dump,
which means basically that they just dug a hole out behind the lodge.
And each day attractor came out with the leftovers and dumped it there.
So what we're talking about here, if you can nasally imagine,
is a big steaming pile of [inaudible] trash,
half eaten food, baking in the sun,
smell wafting in the breeze from miles and miles and into the nostrils of
baboons everywhere.
So it was not long before a troop of baboons not supposed skis,
but one nearby discovered the garbage and just started feeding on it.
And here where there are eating leftover desserts and chicken,
whatever is all dump full of food, must be to a baboo and like,
like venturing into heaven, Manna in the wilderness.
So this troop almost immediately shifted their entire behavior to,
they just slept in the trees above the garbage dump and instead of getting up at
six in the morning to start for Jank, uh,
they would waddle down around two minutes of nine and the tractor would show up
at nine o'clock and dump the food and they would have 20 minutes of sheer frenzy
and then they'd go back to sort of being couch potatoes.
And this is how it went for awhile.
So they're over there living off of garbage and somehow some of the males in my
troop figured this out. These males think we got to get in on this.
We've got to go over there and take their food.
What emerged was each morning a bunch of males would run a kilometer or so,
uh, to the garbage dump and fight their way.
Okay.
Get some of the garbage. So every morning there'd be a showdown basically. Yeah.
And they would come back with canine slashes and stuff like that,
but they'd also have drumsticks, cakes, hamburgers,
and this ritual,
sensible ski went on for years and then a few years into it,
I got word that there were a couple of baboons in this garbage dump troop that
looked awful and something was wrong with them.
Some guys from the lodge had called him and said, hey,
you better get down here and look at this. And when he got there,
what he saw was horrible animals with rotting hands walking on their elbows,
just really bad. So trying to figure out what this is about,
get veterinarians involved and we finally figure out his tuberculosis.
Turns out some infected meat had been thrown in the dump and then eaten by the
baboons. And this was really bad news because while tuberculosis and people,
is it really slow moving disease,
he be kills nonhuman primates in weeks and it's a nightmare of a disease for
them in just a short time. The garbage jump troop was completely decimated.
Not to mention that the tough guys and suppose skis true.
The ones that had gone to the dump every morning,
they got it to have the same kind of rotting hands and they all die of that. Oh,
that must've been really kinda tragic to witness this with is not a good period
for me.
[inaudible]
no, these were my animals. I had, I had grown up with these guys.
But you know,
while suppose ski was heartbroken now that half of the Alpha males in his troop
were dead, he didn't notice some strange things started to happen.
[inaudible]
changes. How do they change? Well, grooming spiked grooming.
So you and I sit on a branch and I take little fleas out of here for, yes. Well,
you know, usually when a female grooms a male, the males never reciprocate,
but suddenly they were even weirder.
You saw adult males sitting in contact with each other and grooming each other.
Oh, you know how, how,
how rare that is be like if I'm suddenly in the middle of round five of a
heavyweight bout Mike Tyson just decided to stop boxing.
[inaudible] clerk comb Evander Holyfield's hair.
You'll be like that if you were a bad mood.
Ologist it would have been less shocking if these guys had wings or were
photosynthetic or something up to then IHC in like 30 seconds of male male
grooming in the course of 15 years.
But at the time supposed to get kind of wrote it off.
It's just some freak event that wasn't going to last.
So he actually stopped studying even after that big investment of time.
Scientifically they were ruined by such a non-natural event,
removing half the study subjects. Oh No.
As a scientist it became less interesting to you. That was the rationale.
It was just too painful to go and watch these guys.
So I moved to the other end of the reserve about 40 miles away and started with
a new troop there and for six years I would not go anywhere near this corner of
the park as I just didn't want to be there.
Now fast forward six years and we come to the moment.
That really changed things for him.
Really flipped him into a different way of thinking and it happened kind of by
accident. So about six years later,
I'm out there for the first time with who was soon destined to become my wife
and decided I wanted to kind of show her where I had grown up.
What part of the park you went to go to? The old haunt? Um, yeah, basically.
So went there and the troop was there and they were acting pretty much the same
as before. Lots of grooming, not so much fighting and isn't that nice?
And they're still like this great remnant troops and he's sitting there with his
wife. It just pointing out all the different baboons on,
there's Tiva and the Arizona, I don't know whoever.
And then it hits him this a Piffen or whatever. Wait a second.
There was only one male left. We'd been there at the time of the TB outbreak.
Got Dawn, don't I don't follow
this one. One meal. Stick with me for just one second and you will get it. Okay.
The thing about male baboons, first thing you can understand is around puberty,
the males get a little ant,
they get itchy, they're bored, and they just pick up and leave.
So in a troupe, any of the adult males grew up someplace else. Richmond,
that these new guys that were coming into supposed skis,
troop were coming in from the outside, from the old world order a Jerky,
real doggy dog world out there.
So you gotta figure these new males are coming in with old expectations that
they're going to have to kick ass to be respected,
which would mean that this whole Koombaya situation should evaporate the moment
these guys show up. But it didn't [inaudible]
[inaudible]
it's stuck. Oh my God. The new guys are learning.
We don't do stuff like that here. And if the new guys are learning a new way,
well that means the old way, the violent way isn't the only way [inaudible]
this, this floored me.
Who was one of those moments.
It will be one of the three or four best silence moments in my life.
The key question was how to these guys unlearn their entire childhood culture of
aggression, Blah, blah,
and somehow learned we don't do stuff like that around here.
Well, well what, well,
how do they unlearn something that was supposedly built in? Um,
well he doesn't really know exactly, oh but, but, but, but here's suppose skis,
hunch. Here's his hunch and this is really cool.
I may have to do with that precarious moment when the new guy comes in.
Now normally what happens in this sort of status quo is that the new guy arrives
and it's just a really bad experience for him.
It's awful. I mean,
you look at them and you just identify with like freshman year at college or
something, they're completely peripheral.
Every male who's higher ranking dumps on them.
And even worse, this freshmen baboons is completely ignored by the ladies.
You just sit there and see somebody groom him. My God,
I went to a sophomore year until somebody groomed him. Come on,
why don't they Google them? Well, because if they did,
some adult male would have attacked them. Oh,
tell the ladies hang back while he's out there biting and climbing and trying to
scratch his way in.
What you've got here is a cycle that is existed for a long,
long time, but if you make one small change,
just remove the Alpha male. Take him out of the equation. Suddenly
the females are more relaxed and more likely to take a social gamble of reaching
out to somebody new. The key thing is the females,
both ski thinks that it's all about timing.
If the females can get to the new guy early enough,
everything is different. It's remarkable. In your typical troop,
and it's three months on average before the
first female grooms you in this trip,
six days can out six days as a compared to three months. Yeah,
and a world in which from day one, as an adolescent male, you're treated better.
Something about the aggressiveness melts away.
[inaudible]
the thing though is jab at a, before we get too carried away,
we do have to ask the question just how permanent this change is.
As Nice as it is.
So I explained this whole story that you've just told to a professor at Harvard
named Richard Wrangham. Yep. Versus the Wrangham is here.
He's an evolutionary biologist. Studies chimps particularly. So I asked him,
well, okay,
you've heard the story about the baboons 40th think y'all know, it's,
it's a nice example of the potential for some change. Uh,
clearly we should put boundaries on it. You know,
lots of baboons have been cited across Africa and this sort of example has never
been found in a natural context, but I think I've used guys,
wild baboons that just happened upon a, a garbage dump. Yeah.
It's just not a very natural context to have humans provide food that leads to
several males dying.
But that means that I could imagine going on a helicopter all over Africa
shooting all the Alpha males and then giving all the ladies a chance to, um,
create a different baboon culture and meet. What I guess I'm wondering is,
do you think in an absurd situation like that,
that the baboons [inaudible] might change its essential nature?
I don't think it'll change its essential nature.
I can see that there can be a cultural influence that may last a little bit of
time,
but the larger influence clearly is the set of of genes that produce a
particular kind of brain of a Boone is basically a baboon until you get some
kind of genetic change.
And that is something that supposedly has not seen though.
So professor writing and once a genetic change to make sure that this is really
real permanent and
yeah, but it's it. But here's the thing.
I don't know if this constitutes a genetic change,
but it has been 20 years [inaudible] yes, 20 years in suppose skis,
original baboons troop is still operating in this peaceful mode even though
dozens of new males have come and gone at this point.
And the idea that something that was thought to be so unchangeable could change
and change quickly and then stay changed as a result of something so airy and
undefinable its culture will that has caused Robert Spolsky dare I say it to
hope absolutely in it's not something that I do by by nature.
Not a hopeful guy by nature. No, not at all. In fact,
the story got him so hopeful.
He decided to send it to Foreign Affairs magazine,
which was a magazine read by a lot of politicians. Yeah. Um,
and they went forward and so we had to ask him after it was published.
Did anyone write you back? Um,
no. Basically not. I basically heard nothing from anyone. No.
From anyone. Yes. Big Yawning silence. I,
I'm sure George Bush and Cheney read at each evening and the tremble at its
implications. But no, basically as far as I can tell,
it was a huge waste of time for me to write it. Ah, well when you read it,
my mother didn't even, all right. So, uh,
so six or seven years have passed as we've mentioned.
And so we decided that it was only right for us to catch up with Robert
Sapolsky. Hello. Well hello is the person next to you taping? You know,
we're trying to close a window here to decrease some noise.
We found him in a very odd place,
actually a for a baboon scientist in the library of the middle school with a
bunch of kids outside. How did that happen?
Like my wife now directs the musical theater productions.
So somehow I'm playing piano as a rehearsal pianist at this school.
What's the musical? Uh, we are doing Oliver this year really
has nothing to do with anything. We should, okay. So anyway,
so I told Robert that we talked to Richard Wrangham reminded him that rang him,
says no, no baboons are hardwired to be a certain way and,
and circumstances never going to change them in the end. Yep. Well he and I, uh,
this, this isn't the first time we've disagreed and I think we probably had a,
we shall see sort of finish. So what,
what have we seen since you last talked to us? What's been happening?
What's been happening? Well, he says, well, there were a few possibilities here.
There's one scenario where it could have turned into exactly what was being
predicted there,
which was that the troop would go back to being a typical,
highly aggressive baboons troops.
The other possibility is the one that I was always like dreaming of,
which is,
so you're a kid who's grown up in that troupe and you've grown up on the commune
there.
And along comes puberty and it's time for you to pick up and you move to a
different troop.
And what happens when the kids who grew up in this babbling culture switch to
other troops now supposedly admits that have just one baboon from the nice Jew
went off to join the meanies, he'd probably get his ass kicked,
but he thinks that if you get two nice baboons together,
they make a little bit of a team and it would be kind of like a critical mass of
niceness that just might spread and turn all the other guys Nice in principle.
This like great unique Pacific culture in these baboons could be transmissible.
Oh, in theory. Okay,
well don't leave us hanging like I what has happened? Okay,
so what actually happened is pretty damn grim.
Do they, did they go back to being mean?
In some sense it's really worse than that. You remember, um,
how this whole thing begins because there's a troop next to [inaudible] and
they'd been eating garbage in a garbage dump, right?
Well eventually supposed skis troop because now the garbage dump is open and
available.
They went over there and began living with the tourist lodge and just living off
of garbage. Now they just sort of squat with the garbage and essentially,
uh, stopped functioning as a coherent troupe.
So this question of will they all become nice baboons eventually,
or will they all revert back to being mean baboons?
That got totally trumped by the garbage situation.
There was so much food to eat for these baboons and it came so free and so
available that the natural business of baboons tree just broke down.
A lot of the males wound up being killed by game park rangers there because as
per usual with the sort of thing,
they got dangerous to the humans there because they got too habituated to
humans. So lots of males were killed.
The rest of the troop is just sort of fragmented.
So I never got to find out what would happen in the long run because the garbage
got in the way again. Yep, exactly. That.
Certainly earlier I've seen your editor. Well.
So the troubling thing here for me is that, you know,
there was a traditional Bevin and culture, which was violent and hierarchical.
There was this hint of a hope of a different baboo and culture,
which was grooming and happiness.
And we had question about which one of those two would spread or, or last.
But the truth is they ran into some junk food and then they have no culture.
Exactly. Which, I hate to say it. That sounds depressingly like America.
Yeah. Um, and there's bunches of them still there. I'm sure as we speak,
actually not as we speak,
but 10 hours from now they'll be waddling over to get some leftovers.
They're probably not missing the culture that they had. But yeah,
those were my guys.
I had my last season out there four years ago and haven't been back since.
No, it sounds like you, you need some, a little, you know,
a little pick her up to quote, uh,
the art that went wrong that we would do anything for you. Anything.
We were climbing a hill. We're adapted.
So just so you know, if you all are, we'll
okay. Oh God,
I had just managed to get that stupid song out of my head rehearsal earlier
today. Thanks a lot.